hello everyone I'm Alana ochar alanazar
and welcome to my channel where today we
are reviewing episodes two and three of
The Last of Us TV show I had originally
planned to after reviewing the first
episode it jumped to doing them all this
podcast like chats with other people but
the day that I said I was going to start
doing that YouTube moved any live
discussions which is what those were
onto a separate tab which I hate
uh and I had all of these people be like
hey I can't find your review of episode
two where is it because it's now in a
separate part of my YouTube channel
which basically means I'm no longer
going to stream live on YouTube
whatsoever at all ever because nobody
can find it when they're looking for it
all streams are now going to be on
Twitch I asked my YouTube Partner
manager if they would change that back
so I can keep streaming on YouTube and
he said they wouldn't
um or didn't imagine they would anytime
soon so that's not happening anymore I
am still going to be doing the
discussion episodes live on Twitch on
Monday nights at 7 pm PT is the plan but
I'm just gonna do solo reviews here as
well uh because why not it's super fun
to talk about it um and I'm not really
on a lot of other social media very much
anymore so having the opportunity to
just like get engaged in the
conversation with people here on YouTube
is really fun and people seem to like
the first one so why not so we're going
to start with episode two I'm also going
to do episode three and then next Monday
uh or Tuesday probably I'll have up the
review of episode four and I'll just do
them solo going forward episode two of
The Last of Us
um started with something that I love
when things can pull this off if you
took the first I'm not sure exactly how
long it is the cold open 10 minutes
maybe of that show and you just pulled
it out it would be one of the best short
films I have ever seen in my life the
tension in that was so potent
I thought they were incredible
performances from the Indonesian actors
they're so heartfelt and honestly bone
chilling obviously you have this police
officer going to pick up a professor
scientist to examine the first example
of cordyceps that they're actually aware
of uh that seems to have you know shown
up in a human and the tendrils out of
the mouth I hate it like the visuals of
that I find so disgusting which I think
is very very very smart of this show to
do including in the test kiss which
there are a lot of things about that
that I didn't like but we'll get to that
I think there are so many zombie shows
right there are so many zombie shows
that end up being very or the humans are
the problem like that's not a unique
take the story of The Last of Us what it
is is really just about love between two
people essentially none of these themes
are terribly unique even though the way
the story is told is obviously moved a
lot of people and is now moving a whole
new group of people through the show
which is awesome but I think what I
really like about the mouth stuff
and more of the stuff that we see in
this episode regarding kind of the hive
mind of the zombies and how they connect
and think is that it makes them
creepier in a way that can actually have
an effect on a modern audience we're
used to zombies zombies are cartooning
zombies are comic bookies zombies as a
concept even the way they appear are not
particularly scary the clickers also do
not have the same effect in the show as
they have in the game they are nowhere
near as scary in my opinion watching the
show while they still look creepy with
their faces all exploded and the sound
design is obviously incredible slash
perfect I believe it's the same voice
actors which is amazing what a fantastic
yet they sound incredible they aren't as
scary because you're not uh worried
about them in terms of the stakes in a
combat scenario you're not worried about
a clicker killing you and making you
start at the beginning again they're
just sort of there clickers were the
most unique the clickers are not as
unique in the show because they're just
kind of a weirder looking zombie what
they've done
to make the concept of a zombie creepy
in this universe is connect them and
have them have tendrils come out of
their mouths it is really creepy
unsettling imagery that I think is kinda
necessary to evoke the response from an
audience that you're looking for where
these life forms are concerned that is
very different to just oh it's The
Walking Dead and they succeeded so
creepy seeing it come out of their mouth
and I was almost expecting a jump scare
in the scene where the scientist is
looking over this body then I was like
oh this is HBO they're not going to give
us a cheap jump scare and they didn't
they just let it sit they let you sit in
dread they let you feel what she's
feeling and then when you cut to the
conversation after that I thought this
was just such fantastic dialogue the cop
says something like what do we do and
the scientist says bombs like I don't
remember what it was exactly but it's
like just bomb all of it blow it all up
as fast as you can and then he says what
do you want to do or what do you want to
take us and she said I'd like to be with
my family those two lines a such a good
way of expressing how dire the
circumstances are it's somebody saying
you have to blow up the entire world I'm
going to die let me just say goodbye to
my family it chilled me to my core I
thought it was such a fantastic way of
showing the stakes from a perspective
that isn't our protagonists who are
obviously living in the modern era
throughout majority of the show I just
thought it was absolutely top tier
excellent so then we jump uh back to
Boston and our story with Joel Ellie and
Tess in episode two is one that um there
are things I like and things I don't
like thing I like I really like the way
that they fleshed out tests a little bit
more in this episode before her untimely
death I felt that I I think I bought the
relationship between Joel and Tess a bit
more in the show than I did in the game
which is interesting and they're almost
the same length they're almost one to
one I think it takes about two hours for
test to die in the game in about two
hours for tested eye on the show which
is crazy maybe two and a half but it's
about that I feel like in the game I
always thought that they like Had Each
Other's backs but um I didn't feel a lot
of love between them necessarily both
very hardened for obvious reasons in the
show I just I bought it a little bit
more which was kind of nice to see that
expanded on and yeah we go from watching
this scene in Jakarta to immediately a
shot of Ellie sitting under a ray of
light and I felt like that was really
purposeful imagery but I could be
reading too much into it that's
something I would have done I've only
directed one uh one short film and it's
not very good but it was all about
imagery that was the the intent the
thing I wanted to learn and I'm like oh
I totally would have gone the bleakest
thing ever to the Hope like the the
Savior sitting under a beam of light oh
beautiful and obviously there's there's
an argument between Tess and Joel and
Ellie and that is sort of similar to
what happens in the game which is
interesting but um yeah I like the
expansion of tests the thing I don't
love and this exists in episode three
still for me as well is Ellie and I
trust that what I don't like about this
is going to change and that like the
experts have decided it needs to be the
way it is for pacing reasons like I'm
very sure of that but what I'll say is
Ellie in the game versus Ellie in the
show and and even if I remove myself to
somebody who loves The Last of Us game
from from this equation Ali in the show
is just a lot meaner and when we're
trying to be carried through this
journey based on the relationship of
these two people they are much kinder to
each other much faster in the game Ellie
is a lot sweeter she's not as snarky
she's not as rude she doesn't swear
quite as much she still swears but not
quite as much and and it's you know
definitely been interesting watching
them literally back to back like I
watched the end of episode two and then
I played the end of episode two in the
game and that's it's just an interesting
thing to see the comparison of of how
Ellie really doesn't like Joel doesn't
seem to want anything to do with him
whereas in the game it's not like she's
happy about the situation but she's just
a lot softer and sweeter and kinda and I
wonder if maybe that's a thing that
needs to be present in the video game so
that you you know actually care about
the person that you are escorting that
you are saving that you personally are
taking on this journey with you it
needed to happen faster in the show
right now I still don't even really buy
that they like each other and I
definitely felt that way throughout
episode two in a way that I wasn't a big
fan of and and actually I felt even
worse about it in episode three but
again I'm sure that they'll get that I
am not concerned so the relationship
between Tess and Ellie was one that I
feel like was nicely fleshed out for the
short time that they're together even if
Ellie's reaction to the death was
certainly a little bit extreme I get
that it's horrific leaving somebody
behind is terrifying this is one of her
first times being in the outer World um
but she's like no we can't leave her no
in the game she's a bit more chill
speaking of which Ellie's first time out
of the QC I thought that this episode
episode 2 was just so visually stunning
just oh my God the way the city looked
my brain knew things with CGI but I
couldn't tell you what was CG it just
looked absolutely incredible the
attention to detail all of the setup
going through the museum and and seeing
the similarities to the game is also
awesome obviously like for us as Gamers
but just just beautiful in the show as
well just absolutely Blown Away by the
production value of the show it's it's
incredible it looks amazing and then
here we see that big mass of zombies on
the ground that big pile and we learn
about this network and the fact that
Joel's the one that actually triggers
them all to know that they're there in
the museum was an interesting choice too
so yeah the journey in this episode
really fun incredible to watch
well-paced action good drama beautiful a
lot of things to love about it it's it's
fantastic it's so well done it's it's
just incredible then we get to test eye
similar circumstances obviously she's
been bitten love to see the comparison
between seeing how her body bite has
changed and how Ellie's has not to prove
that to Joel so that he actually starts
to believe that she is the cure it's
still a beautiful sacrifice it's still
it's still what she does there and her
desperation is the fire that Joel needs
to even continue helping Ellie at all is
it's somebody he loves being like hey
I'm effectively dying for this go do it
and I I think that setup is just really
smart it was smart in the game it's
modding the show um I maintain that
there are a lot of things in the show
that are the same but it really doesn't
feel like fan service it feels like it
was just the right thing to say it was
just well written to begin with turns
out I think the lighter thing when you
know it's gonna work and that's not how
those lighters work it is a little bit
silly she's constantly flicking a
lighter that has no gas it's just a bit
of a cliche but it certainly makes it
very tense and then of course we have a
infected walk up to
um a test and kiss her and I get why
this happened it happened because it
recognized that she was already infected
and was trying to get her to be part of
the network faster clearly didn't work
fast enough because she was still smart
enough to look down and drop the light
up but again I respect how creepy that
is and the difference in zombie um is an
approach that I appreciate I just it's
it's so weird that it really took me out
of the what the drama of what was
happening it feels like a preference
more than a criticism to me it was just
like an odd sexualization of somebody
who is like sort of become a mother
figure in a way that they die I don't I
just it felt unnecessary to me to make
that that sacrifice be a sort of sexual
and as a slow kiss just it's just it was
just a bit odd in a way that I I didn't
feel at it is it disgusting yes for sure
which I'm sure is what they were going
for but not in a way that like made me
feel like the world was any more fully
realized or like that death was any more
important or like the zombies were any
more scary it was just strange I just
wasn't a fan but I get that it ties into
also the consistency with uh everything
spreading through these tendrils and
this network rather than through spores
which is obviously a big change from the
game that I completely understand
overall I felt like this episode was
maybe a little bit fast for episode two
a little bit too fast I would have liked
it to be a tiny bit slower to have
little more tidbits of tests probably
learn a little bit more about her and
and the relationship with Joel and chess
but I loved it I thought it was
absolutely brilliant I really really
liked it episode three obviously very
different very very different to what I
was expecting very different to what's
in the game and there are like two ways
to talk about episode three one
just as an episode of TV I think I would
call this one of the best episodes of TV
that I've ever seen it was so
heartbreaking the fact that there are
two characters that we've just been
introduced to in this episode
who give you all of this extra context
to life inside of this world which is
what they're serving really is what
matters when you come into a world like
this here's here's a look at somebody
who has actually built something that
operates uh in the way that you'd always
be like why didn't somebody just do this
he's done it that is what bill has done
um and getting to see that come together
and how he lives and then also the
direct focus of hey what actually
matters is relationships and love you
can have this whole thing you can have
built this whole thing what do they
actually mean to any of us same as like
Joel leaving the quarantine zone right
what does it mean to any of us if you
don't have a person you love with you or
family or friends or companionship what
does it actually mean and I thought that
that as a as a setup for that point of a
show and a story that is really about
again love between two humans and and
caring for another human that's really
what the last of us is about while also
giving the extra context of again a
different version of life outside of the
quarantine Zone and some of the options
for how people survived was fantastic
but also just the way it played out
because it's very different from what
happens in the game I love that I didn't
know and this is the thing that I said
from the original trailers that I stand
by I never feel like I want a story to
be remade one for one and I kept saying
that in trailers I was worried it would
be too similar this is just my stance I
know some people want a direct
adaptation 100 I don't like that because
I just play the game I think the game is
so well made that if I wanted a
one-to-one adaptation I would just play
the game it's so fantastic I wanted a
different take I wanted things to be
different it is very different obviously
here and for me it works a couple of
things again that I don't love first
thing I didn't love just to get it out
of the way because it's in the actual
order of the show Joel and Ellie's
relationship in the startups episode
really wasn't a fan the fact that she
shows No Remorse for tests really at all
and it's just kind of rude to Joel it's
a little hard to redeem in my head in
the game she's still like hey I'm sorry
about tests in the show when we think
she's going to say that she goes I
wasn't gonna say I'm sorry no you're
wrong I wasn't going to apologize and
she's like making joke books and he's
basically mourning the person that he's
been with and like they walk into the
store and and Ellie makes a comment like
so you're going to answer my question or
not it's like she's just so rude like I
feel like there was a lot of hostility
between the two of them in a way that I
found Ellie annoying which I have not at
all found in the game at any point ever
I think Ellie's kind of has to be
lovable again when you're trying to
carry it through something and again
just like mean like she's just really
mean to a guy who just lost the woman
that he loved like it was harsh again
something I don't love but I suspect
that that is in favor of a character
Rock we are going to see her soften and
see them become closer and she's getting
this Father Figure she's just still very
resistant to it thinks she's independent
thinks she's a badass you have to have a
defined character Arc that's different
in a TV show to it is in a game where
you are having an escort this go through
it so you have to care about her
immediately basically very different
types of writing for sure so I imagine
that we're going to get there it's just
something that to me was like she kind
of sucks and then yeah so so then we
actually get to everything that happens
with Bill and Frank which of course was
referenced in the games but we'd never
actually seen and very cool to see some
of Bill's backstory fleshed out even if
we don't actually end up seeing Joel and
Ellie meet him the way that they
normally would but it was really cool to
see more of that and more of what that
meant and yeah you just hauled us
through this story of of flushing this
world out of what it is like to survive
outside of the qz and and what is
important and then to have that happen
and not know what was going to happen
beautiful performances from both of them
I thought Nick Offerman the way he's
playing a little bit agitated a little
bit anxious
ah I just it was so moving I just
thought it was absolutely incredible
performance both of them really I mean
it was amazing the food the wine all of
these things that we actually aren't
seeing in the qz the fineries the the
going to different stores and doing them
up a lot of things that I thought were
really nice to get a glimpse of that
version of what this kind of Apocalypse
is like you know the first thing I
didn't like about this I knew that bill
was gay going into this episode and I
felt like the way that they tried to
tell the TV audience that bill was gay
was pretty weird like a comment on oh of
course you know what kind of wine goes
with rabbit because he's gay is that a
thing we need to do I know plenty of
Street dudes who know what wine to pair
with rabbit uh definitely and to do it
they made a few comments like that that
were like yeah I know what kind of man
you are but I like just making gay
stereotypes it was strange to me I found
that romance holy like believable and
and the complexities of it and some of
the lines of like yeah I've had bad days
some of my worst days have been with you
but I'm still here um probably recording
that terribly but some of that was
really really really powerful and real
and God it was just so sad and it sad in
a way that again the way that existed
was such a good Standalone feature film
it was just beautiful heartbreaking yeah
I loved that I didn't know what was
going to happen especially when he's
drinking the wine I was like I think
he's probably gonna kill himself as well
but I don't know if he is and then he
did and the way that they end the
episode on the shot of like they didn't
go into the bedroom but it's the camera
like pans back into the bedroom so you
just see the window and you know that
the window's open that's how you know
it's the bedroom damn dude so then I how
it departs from the game again I was
always in the camp if you go watch my
trailer reactions of wanting it to be
different that's me that's how I feel
about it I don't want to see the same
thing in a different medium I want a
different thing so it was cool and when
I think about it there's some cool stuff
that we lost that is kind of sad to not
have some conversations between Bill and
Ellie that are really funny and
certainly the whole thing with the
school I imagine the bloater is
completely gone but when thinking about
it I think if we had put those things in
the show at this point at episode 3 it
would be a little silly and I don't
think it would necessarily serve the
story anywhere near as well again there
are a lot of things that work in
gameplay that don't work in TV and vice
versa if you were just meeting this dude
who has this Farm to go get a battery
which is really all he is in the game go
to a school and fight something and have
certainly some cool action sequences but
I don't think they serve the story of
love and Humanity inside an apocalypse
anywhere near as well as what they
actually did do they served the game and
I'm glad the game has that you know
that's super fun in the game it's very
fun gameplay session but in a show I
think that's some of it's a little bit
over the top it's a little bit cartoony
it's very gory violent and it doesn't
again it doesn't really serve the story
of these two people even if I'm like oh
that's a bummer like there's things that
I'm bummed to not see to have it be
replaced with like an incredible love
story of two people in this world how
they live out their lives very very
differently to test in a Joel and then
to have the note at the end really be
the point of the episode for Joel who's
still again hard to Ellie who's this is
kind of the first time you see them
slightly soften even if I feel like a
little bit unearned that the note says
something like that's the kind of men we
are use these to look after tests you
know coming from someone who used is
effectively wealth in this world to look
after Frank who was dying Joel is using
his skills to look after Ellie now it's
something that is more important than
Tess really and it's just another person
being like hi I Died For Love how does
this make you feel here's my last words
it's written to Joel never really liked
you that much and I love that they did
keep his character like shitty like he's
still a dick I thought that was good and
to be like yeah that's this is the kind
of menu this is what we do this is what
you do is I think just extra motivation
for Joel and just a treat for the
audience again to just see a different
take on life in this world and even
though again bums do not have certain
things the change makes sense to me and
I'm excited to see things be different
personally I'm playing through part one
right now I'm still playing through the
game the game is still there I'm cool
with it I of course know some people
probably won't be cool with it because
it's so different and I'm not going to
fault you for that either I do want to
be like we'll just go play the game it's
fine but if he was signing up for like
horror zombie show it's not that and I
guess my thing is that the last of us
has never been horror zombie show to me
it has always been about humans and
human relationships and this really just
tied that in nicely so I I thought it
was beautiful the only thing I'm
currently not liking and that I didn't
like about
um episode 3 was it's early more than
anything I feel like she's a little bit
too harsh obviously I'm comparing her to
game Ellie and maybe I wish I couldn't
because I think maybe I would feel
differently but she was just kind of
rude in some instances and I don't
really like seeing them together that
much unfortunately which is a big Obama
but again I'm just assuming people are
to get there so that is how I feel about
episode two and three I'll have another
review of episode four up next week I'm
really enjoying the show so far and
again it's really cool to have it be
different so I don't know exactly what's
gonna happen 100 of the time that's just
really nice I am streaming uh episodes
during the week before the next episode
so I'll probably stream in the next
couple of days to catch up to the end of
episode three so that will be to when we
leave Bill and uh talk showy podcasty
thing on Twitch every Monday night at 7
pm PT this one is going up Tuesday night
at 7 15 PM PT just because I had to make
this change that I'm making right now we
have some cool guests lined up
um I'm gonna have Kate Siegel and Mike
Flanagan on an episode Carl Jacobs is
gonna be on an episode of Lucy James
um destiny a bunch of cool friends uh uh
gonna be joining me to talk about all
these different episodes so I will be
putting them up on Twitch live and then
I will put the podcast episodes on here
uploaded as well so for The Last of Us
content at the moment but it's fun the
show is awesome so yeah thank you for
watching everyone I'm Alana I'll see you
guys next time